[Música]
[Aplausos]
creo que me ayuden y les voy a hacer dos
preguntas tiene aquí está harto de la
corrupción levante la mano y diga yo muy
fuerte
[Aplausos]
muy bien veo muchas manos levantadas
segunda pregunta quién de aquí ha
cometido un acto de corrupción o conoce
a alguien que ha cometido un acto de
corrupción
[Aplausos]
de nuevo veo muchas manos levantadas y
es justamente de lo que va esta plática
como nosotros somos una sociedad como
mexicanos que tenemos una relación de
amor-odio con la corrupción por un lado
nos encanta estarnos quejando de ésta
pero al mismo tiempo lo promovemos y el
otro día estaba yo tratando de buscar
ninguna imagen que lo ejemplificar a muy
bien y no encontré una imagen por
encontrar este tweet
como por un lado sabemos que nos está
haciendo daño pero al mismo tiempo lo
seguimos fomentando lo seguimos
promoviendo no queremos darnos cuenta
que nos está haciendo daño es más creo
que te hemos normalizado la corrupción
ya está nos sorprendemos cuando alguien
es honesto el otro día estaba manejando
escuchando la radio porque sí aunque no
lo crean los millennials también
escuchamos la radio cuando no tenemos
pil en el teléfono
y la gran noticia de la que los
locutores estuvieron hablando casi diez
minutos era de un policía que se había
encontrado una bolsa con dinero y la
había regresado
o sea el policía hizo su chamba esa era
la noticia y diez minutos hablaron de lo
sorprendente que había sido que este
funcionario público regresar el dinero
yo estoy seguro que esa noticia no sería
tan relevante en países que no tienen
problemas de corrupción pero les repito
somos una sociedad que nos encanta
echarle la culpa al gobierno pero
nosotros nos ponemos de nuestra parte y
lo podemos también ver en materia de
seguridad en méxico una persona de cada
diez denuncia un delito pero les aseguro
es más es más la cantidad que lo va a
apostar en facebook no siempre está aquí
te metes a facebook y ya sabes que
alguien asaltaron pero pregúntale oye y
ya ve levantaste tu denuncia hiciste lo
que te toca como ciudadano y miren yo no
voy a defender al gobierno ni a los
políticos la verdad es que nos han
tocado políticos bastante corruptos
bastante cerdos con todo respeto para
los cerdos
porque es importante hablar de la
corrupción en nuestra sociedad más de
más de la mitad de los mexicanos ha dado
un soborno alguna vez en su vida y que
nos cuesta a nosotros los mexicanos la
corrupción pues bueno la corrupción nos
cuesta el 9 por ciento del producto
interno bruto que es más o menos el
total del producto interno bruto de
países como ecuador méxico está evaluado
como 29 sobre 100 según transparencia
internacional en percepción de la
corrupción 29 sobre 100 no saben mi mamá
ya me hubiera reventado chancletazos con
un 29 sobre 100
pero me di cuenta de algo el año pasado
al final estos son números son datos
estadísticos si me piden que le expliqué
a un niño pequeño que es el pib
probablemente falle pero me di cuenta
que la corrupción tiro el revés amén
que la corrupción tiro edificios que
estaban construidos de manera irregular
con permisos que no se debieron de haber
dado en la colonia del valle y en muchas
otras zonas de méxico todo eso me di
cuenta el 19 de septiembre y yo creo que
lo que más nos duele a los mexicanos de
la corrupción es la impunidad y para
variar podemos hablar de casos muy
sonados recientemente uno el primero que
está arriba la estafa maestra donde el
gobierno mexicano a través de
universidades públicas desapareció vamos
a decir eso 7 mil millones de pesos 7
mil millones de pesos podemos hablar de
over break el escándalo internacional en
latinoamérica donde ya hay presidentes
que están siendo investigados y hay
altos funcionarios en la cárcel en otros
países y en méxico no pasa de una
carpeta de investigación y seguramente
se va a quedar en un carpetazo alguien
reconoce esta ciudad
alguien que me diga cuál es esta ciudad
por favor a ver
monterrey muy bien hay dos cosas que le
admiro mucho a las personas de monterrey
1 su impresionante habilidad para
aprender un asador en menos de 5 minutos
yo me tardo hasta 20 así y 2 como en el
año 2011 pudieron reducir sus niveles de
inseguridad en el 2011 en monterrey era
una ciudad que amanecía a menos tres a
menos cuatro y no estoy hablando de
grados centígrados estoy hablando de
personas desaparecidas
estoy hablando que en monterrey en
aquella época había balaceras casi
semanales y no fue hasta que estas tres
esferas trabajaron en conjunto que se
pudo lograr una solución hoy monterrey
no es la ciudad más segura del mundo
pero sí es mucho más segura de lo que
era hace unos años cómo tienen que
actuar estas tres esferas la sociedad
civil tiene que ser congruente con lo
que le pide al gobierno quienes
políticos y políticos son estos sean
estos es tu parte como ciudadano señala
qué es lo que está mal y no seas
cómplice el sector empresarial sacando
los permisos que se deben sacar haciendo
negocios formales el gobierno dando
incentivos a las empresas para que
tengan los permisos formales
y sancionar más fuerte a las empresas y
a los políticos y dar muerte civil a los
políticos corruptos para que no puedan
seguir participando y dañando a nuestro
país
esta frase me gusta mucho no te
preguntes qué puede hacer tu país por ti
pregúntate qué puedes hacer tú por tu
país
el otro día estaba manejando yo otra vez
manejando y me dio una vuelta que no me
debí haber dado que para una patrulla y
pues vaya lo primero que ve es que soy
joven entonces como wii joven yo que
paso oficial es que se dio una vuelta
que no se debió haber dado y yo bueno
que sí ya me quiero ir eran las 3 de la
mañana iba regresando dejar una amiga a
su casa y dice un joven o es que le va a
salir carísimo la multa a ver pase me de
su licencia y su tarjeta de circulación
de la pasó y me dice que mi tarjeta de
circulación está vencida yo ni siquiera
sabía que eso se vencía y pues va el
tercero un joven no es que va a tener
que ser corralón
oh dios mío dios mío le marcó a mi papá
tres de la mañana papá gracias por
contestar la cosa está así y mi papá es
muy sabio y él cree en el conocimiento
empírico qué es eso el aprendizaje
vivencial en otras palabras él no iba a
salir por mí a las 3 de la mañana iba a
tener que solucionarlo yo
y pues bueno le dije al oficial está
bien lo que vayas a hacer
hazlo ya porque son tres de la mañana
estamos en una zona en la que no me
siento muy seguro y si te vas a ver
coche con la grúa y llévatelo ya pasó
una hora desde que le dije eso hasta que
finalmente se lo llevó una hora en la
que me intimidó una hora en la que
intentó llegar a una solución
alternativa más amigable para las dos
partes como le quieran llamar a ustedes
y fue una hora en la que yo pude haber
sacado mi cartera darle un billete de
200 pesos
creo e irme
pero al final decidí hacer lo correcto
porque con la inocencia de un niño
pequeño que puede diferenciar muy bien
entre lo que está bien y lo que está mal
actual ese día les voy a ser honestos no
siempre lo hago así por ese día sentí
muy bonito hacerlo al día siguiente y
fui al corralón saqué mi coche y ese día
perdí un poco de dinero perdí todo un
día hasta mi mamá salí involucrada en
este asunto y lo solucione de la manera
correcta y hoy en día me tomo a mí como
ejemplo en esa situación cada vez que me
veo de nuevo en una situación parecida y
me gusta saber que por lo menos ese día
hice las cosas bien y así día con día
pensar hoy lo voy a volver a hacer bien
quiero terminar con una historia que me
contó un amigo que desafortunadamente no
está aquí hoy con nosotros
está de vacaciones no se preocupen
había una vez un mundo que era
completamente oscuro en este mundo
completamente oscuro habitaban puntitos
negros muchos puntos negros
estos puntos negros me gusta pensar son
las personas corruptas las personas
deshonestas y también me gusta pensar
que estos puntos negros son las personas
que se quedan calladas y que deciden
actuar que solo van a fluir con los
demás puntos negros un día un punto
negro decide alzar la voz cambiar su
forma de ser dejar de ser corrupto dejar
de ser como los demás y ese punto negro
se cambia a color a un punto azul un
punto rojo el color que ustedes quieran
un punto blanco vaya y a partir de ese
punto aquel mundo que era completamente
negro se convirtió en un mundo casi
completamente negro muchas gracias
[Aplausos]